[Applaudissements]
l'anneau olympique de richmond au sud de
vancouver c'est l'exemple parfait d'une
installation qui ont été construites
pour les olympiques mais dont on
continue à servir
après les jeux en 2010 leur des yeux
c'était le style de compétition pour le
patinage de vitesse et depuis le site a
été transformé en complexe multisports
et même les joueurs de ping pong ce
dimanche s'ils entraient au total pour
des jeux de 2010
cette installation sportive ont été
construites cinq autres ont été rénovés
et à l'exception du site de saut à ski
est un sport qui n'est pas très
populaire au canada la plupart des
infrastructures olympiques sont
aujourd'hui largement utilisé par les
résidents de la grande région de
vancouver y sol
c'est ce qu'avait planifier les
organisateurs so we on s'est d'abord
demandé comment on a utilisé les
installations après les jeux et si
seulement par la suite qu'on s'est
demandé comment on pouvait intégrer les
olympiques
à l'intérieur de ces infrastructures on
est donc loin le parc olympique laissé à
l'abandon comme celui de sotchi
[Musique]
les jeux olympiques sont aussi
l'occasion d'investir dans les
infrastructures non sportives comme le
transport en commun et aucun doute que
pour moi le plus grand c'est juste
ajouter des jeux olympiques c'est notre
enfant comme ce qu'a cru ça permet aux
gens de venir de l'aéroport des
touristes
les visiteurs qui peuvent aller jusqu'au
centre-ville de vancouver
et quand on additionne tous ces projets
d'infrastructures mais aussi les coûts
de sécurité et d'opérations pour les
jeux de vancouver
on arrive à une facture totale qui
dépasse les 7 milliards de dollars
c'est moins qu'à pyongchang beaucoup
moins qu à sotchi mais un peu plus que
ce que prévoient dépenser calgary en
2026 si elle accueille les jeux donc les
jeux de vancouver est quand même parmi
les moins chers des dernières années et
surtout dit les organisateurs il n'y a
pas eu de dépassement de coûts
faramineux
comme on a pu voir à montréal par
exemple là où l'impact des jeux est
peut-être plus faible que certains le
prévoyaient c'est sur les retombées
touristiques à long terme il n'y a pas
eu après les olympiques de bond
spectaculaire de visiteurs allant
couvert vous dire que c'était une ville
qui jouissait déjà d'une très bonne
réputation à l'international
mais quand même si on dit que le grand
héritage des jeux de 2010 ce sont toutes
les installations qui ont été données à
la communauté
on peut se demander est ce qu'on aurait
pu construire toutes ces infrastructures
mais sans avoir les jeux et sans payer
pour la sécurité pour les coûts
d'opération pour la billetterie
selon cet urbaniste ça a été dit si les
olympiques ont motivé tout le monde pour
créer des facilités qui autrement
auraient pris beaucoup plus donné être
réalisés pour les athlètes aussi les
olympiques sont l'occasion d'aller
chercher plus de financement ça prend
absolument des événements majeurs pour
qu ailleurs une augmentation au niveau
du financement et puis c'est quelque
chose qu'on a vu avec l'avènement des
jeux de 2010 et puis autour de 2010 des
financements rsa environ le même est
fini maintenant on se retrouve en
situation on est un peu derrière le
reste du monde à cause de la matière à
réflexion donc pour calgary qui songe à
se porter candidate aux jeux d'hiver de
l'investissement l'impé pu contribuer
autant au développement urbain au
dépassement sportif si laurence parfait
radio canada vancouver